i think notebooks are great for ideas
i think like a well-managed to-do list
is a software product that you need to
adopt and there's like 80 of them i
actually don't even care which one you
adopt but it's like
when i like tell something to founders
and then they write it down in a
notebook i'm like that's gone forever
but they look cool they have like a
fountain pen and they're like taking
beautiful notes michael we all know that
everything important is
this is michael seibel with dalton
caldwell today we're going to talk about
how future billionaires get [ __ ] done
so dalton you were inspired by a pg
boast when thinking of this idea right
yeah paul graham wrote this really
famous blog post um i believe called
maker schedule manager schedule where
you know
he said something that all of us had
thought before but he put it very
succinctly and in great words and so if
you haven't read it before anyone out
there on the internet um you should read
it just google make your schedule
manager schedule we can put a link in
and he introduces the idea of the
difference between how makers ie
programmers in his case organize their
time to be productive versus folks that
are managers all right and so it's great
terminology it's good stuff yes
so let's start with the maker mode
you were a developer in your startup i
was a business guy in my startup i think
in many ways this stuff came a little
bit more
um
natively to you
and i had to learn this stuff by like
basically destroying the productivity of
my co-founders so
how did you think about makers mode as a
founder
most companies
are set up around a manager schedule
where you have a day packed with meeting
after meeting and so if you're a
programmer at a big company you would
have to
you know you'd have like an hour to
program here an hour to program there
and
this is bad
this was not conducive to to building
things okay and so to just walk through
my perspective of someone that
you know was programming back in the day
when i when i was a startup founder
um
when you're programming
the more of the program you can keep in
your head at any one time
the the easier it is for you to know
what's going on and have the context up
here to make changes and fix bugs and it
takes like an hour or two
cold
of looking at a program and figuring
stuff out for it to get loaded into ram
so to speak
and so if you're interrupted
like if you have to program in hour
increments
man are you gonna suck
like you constantly
have to restart your state every time
you program and so a great maker
schedule is something like an eight-hour
uninterrupted block of time and his
argument i think he was also
talking about this from the perspective
of an artist or a musician like if you
wanted to record an album or write music
or if you wanted to write a book the
same deal if you had to write a book in
20-minute increments
i think a lot of writers wouldn't love
that
fair
which is so much different than the
business guy like i you know i was the
business guy at my startup and
you certainly can do email
in 20 minute increments
or hour increments
and so i remember having this
conversation with emmett where he said
michael imagine that i'm doing
ridiculously complicated word problems
and you're interrupting me in the middle
of them
and i was like then it clicked i was
like oh well i've had to do hard work
like like i went to school i had to do
that [ __ ] that's what your day is like
one that sounds a lot harder than
writing emails but two
i would hate to be interrupted like that
and once he said that it kind of clicked
um before he said that i just assumed
well you know he's typing on typing yeah
he's typing things
and and i remember i remember when i
read the post what resonated with me is
i felt like my work day really began
around five or six pm isn't that weird
and that's because what that's when
things would quiet down and i would stop
getting email and the building i was
working out of would quiet down and
that's where actually all the good
programming happened was at the end of
the day
what was interesting was that
for us
we basically had to figure out how to
build that in i think in the beginning
organically it happened because you know
that was our sleep cycle we were all
living in an apartment together but when
we had more employees we had an office
you know we literally and this is
something that i just noticed happened
organically nothing got done before
lunch
like getting to work was all about like
getting in answering your email doing a
couple meetings like it was just like
no one who was writing code even wanted
to start writing code before lunch
because lunch was the big like fu in the
middle of the day
and our whole trick was
one how do we not serve a lunch makes
everyone go to sleep
and two how do we make that post lunch
time
free of everything
pg in some ways
designed yc a little bit that way right
i think that's counterintuitive to a lot
of founders like one
there aren't that many events you don't
have classes all day at yc like you know
we try to take as little time as
possible during your week so you can
actually get [ __ ] done
two there's a hard deadline
demo day
and three i think people are often
surprised like
a good portion of yc is just asking you
what are you going to accomplish by demo
day
and then asking you every week well did
you do it
yep and it's you confronting the yes or
no of that like
it turns out that like
there's a lot of magic on that and he
wanted to build as much maker time as
possible in the program i think in this
kind of balance between maker mode and
manager mode
what people should be trying to do is
maximize their productivity when they're
in that mode
right how do you maximize productivity
so when i think about manager mode for
me i always like to think about this
like
okay if i'm going to be managing my time
between my to-do list which is
just another way of saying [ __ ] that's
actually important to get done
meetings
email
and slack
i always think that my to-do list comes
first like whenever i'm being productive
i start at the to-do list
and i do everything there and then i
check those things whenever i control it
yes versus if it's inbox driven
other people are in control of your time
which is watch out
horrible
horrible the second thing is around
meetings and like we talk about this a
lot like you're gonna have to have some
meetings
um
i've seen a couple tricks but they can
all be reduced down to write [ __ ] down
the worst thing is when you have to have
another meeting because people didn't
write the [ __ ] down from the first
meeting
like like that is like when you know
you've punched yourself in the
face but like i'm so shocked it's like
no one again let me push you on that
because you and i agree but let me let
me let's make this clear the audience
what are we saying what we mean is say
you and i are an immediate we agree on
something
if narus writes it down it's like it
never happened
it's like we just
we were like patting ourselves on the
back what a great meeting right michael
no one writes it down we're like what do
we talk about
even if i didn't think i needed it
oh let's write down the agenda oh let's
write our notes where we decided uh
that would be great any other things
that have made you productive as a
manager the number one thing
that i do that i realize that a lot of
the other successful founders did too
was i
had my analytics dashboard or whatever
was important kpis on the business up on
my screen 24 7 and i would stare at it
all the time and i actually could
memorize
i even this is even the case for yc man
i don't even know if you know this but
like a lot of our internal stats i have
memorized yes
and it's because i stare at them all the
time and no one told me to do that this
is just a me thing
but i'm like obsessed
with like the internal key kpis for
anything i'm working on i'm just like an
addict to look at that stuff
i think that that is such what we see on
the other side and i completely agree
with you that was a huge thing
especially for my second startup that
was a really huge thing
it's funny when you talk to a founder
who knows their stats well
they just talk about their stats so
differently you know like
man like the first of all they don't
round off numbers to the nearest like
zero you know like
but second of all they know whether
they're up or down 10 percent at like at
any given time like at any given time
whereas other founders is like yeah i
think it was an up week but
it's like how do you not know
how do you not know if your revenue like
went up this week like
what are you what are you doing yeah no
i i don't get it i don't get when
someone is like operating a business and
it's like what was i do we what was our
revenue last month
but but like keeper they they give that
to me at the end of the month and it's
like what like
or people didn't know i mean for us it
was you know daus and it was like amount
of video watched but it's like
everyone
on the founding team knew when we had
less traffic today than yesterday
everyone right like just just like in
like in their bones like
oh i i think my last point on this
manager schedule the thing i would just
add is what i've learned that i did not
appreciate when i was a founder
is that
the maker schedule vibe works for sales
and talking to customers too
and scheduling 20 minute blocks to talk
to customers
is not the same as an eight-hour
like
like even if it's not literally your
programmer
using the maker's concept to apply to
the things that are the main event of
your startup at any one time and for
many folks that is sales yes yeah you
should be scheduling eight-hour blocks
like if you're if you're if your job is
the co-founder is to be doing sales
and it's like a couple of slivers in
between other things on your schedule
i don't think that's gonna go well
you know right it's interesting i agree
with you it's basically this idea of get
all of this stupid crap
so productive that you can clear out
that every founder can clear out a chunk
of their time for the make your schedule
and like some founders gonna have to do
more of this
non-development blocking tackling others
are gonna have to do less of it but
i completely agree with you like it's
really hard to get anything at a high
level done in 20 minute blocks
let's talk though about the opposite of
all these things right so
you know the premise of this chat is how
future billionaires get [ __ ] done
let's talk about what we see
great founders not do
what comes to mind dalton
what are founders avoiding look i think
the trickiest thing for everybody
is social media it's like a social media
is the black hole for time yes and you
know we're all guilty of it too like
it's addictive and so what's tricky
is how to have a healthy relationship
with social media
so that you aren't spending 24 7 paying
attention to who the main character on
twitter is that said something dumb and
everyone's like making fun of them it's
so hard not to do that constantly and
it's also not hard to think that like
you are a startup founder and you're
succeeding and you like did well
but if i actually if like a like a
hidden camera was shadowing you through
the day it was like you just read
twitter all day
you know what i'm saying like imagine if
there was like a hidden camera auditing
what people actually did with a lot of
their time
i think some people out there would be
pretty embarrassed if there was a full
clear-eyed accounting of where their
time went so okay discord
here um
techcrunch here twitter here you know
it's like how much time are you actually
spending on not those things
you know it's hard man i had a twitter
problem
and you know one of the things that i
realized is that
sometimes willpower isn't enough you
know like what i did was i follow
unfollowed everyone on twitter
and then i installed this like chrome
app that basically disables like three
quarters of twitter's features
and i was just you know it was like this
is an addictive thing i need an
intervention
and that did it like that kind of killed
my twitter because it was just like oh
well and it was funny because for a
while twitter kept on trying to feed me
interesting articles and interesting
stuff but it was
they couldn't really do it because i was
not following anyone i wasn't really
interacting with many tweets and so
eventually just like
it broke but yeah i mean i i uninstalled
facebook years ago so i don't have it i
don't have notification turns on i don't
have the twitter app installed on my
phone
so again like
everyone should do what works for them
but
i'm
people that actually are super
productive
do abnormal things to turn all this crap
off yeah isn't that like you have to
like
aggressively be abnormal
on protecting your time yes because if
you don't the world is going to steal
your time from you it's going to steal
your energy from you
and like
that's a bad trade-off if you're a
startup founder man yeah what a waste of
time
you know it's funny it's like it's
almost like these two sets of tools
there's one set of tools
that allow you to organize your time
better and there's another set of tools
that protect your time and
yeah effective people use both
constantly and i think ineffective
people sometimes are mistaken and they
think
if i were just had a stronger will i
like needing tools is the problem
like successful people are just have a
stronger will and that's like not true
it's like no success people reach for
tools all the time
like successful people recognize their
weaknesses and actually reach for tools
now here's the one that comes up a lot
the collecting of
mentors advisors weird credentials like
advice oh i went through
three different accelerators and an idea
lab oh my advisory board i'm building my
advisory board
why do you think founders are attracted
to that versus just building something
and launching it it smells like you're
doing successful startup stuff you're
like part of the community of startup
this and you know like there's all this
stuff you can do and
i'm not saying like it's all bad but
it's
it's a bottomless pit of time suck like
you could go so far deep in there
you could be in that bottomless pit for
years
and be a startup founder that's never
built a product and has never gotten a
single customer because you just cycled
in and out of various forms of startup
mentorship
it's weird it's like going to hollywood
and getting acting lessons
yes and like you just you you're in like
this acting lessons mode for like years
and you're like yeah i'm an actor and
it's like you know what i'm saying like
it feels like you're making progress
right but you're not
you know i think a lot of it also has to
do with founders being a little bit
afraid and thinking these things do risk
well if i have an advisory board it's
going to de-risk my startup it's a bunch
of smart people saying my idea is good
or if i do a bunch of mentorship it
de-risks my startup i get a lot of
advice and
i don't know the thing we keep on saying
over and over again is like the two
things that really
ridiculously de-risk your startup three
things and we'll get to the third one
the second first one's talking your
customers the second one is building a
launching product like and it's like god
forbid you're doing anything
more than you're doing those things you
are not taking the optimal de-risk
strategy like
um and then the last one
we see a lot of people trying to hedge
their bets
so many people trying to be like well
i'm keeping grad school open
i've got a google job offer i've got a
jane street or whatever the new
tech finance thing
of the minute is
and i'm talking to three friends about
doing a startup
and like i'm kind of moving all those
pieces down the board at the same time
and like we get asked questions like
okay so how do i optimize this i'm like
i don't i don't think you can be great
at those four things at the same time
like it's hard enough to be great at one
of those things
but like once again like why should i
have like why shouldn't i hedge delton
like isn't the optimal move to hedge
like how do i know making the right
decision
when you're taking a high risk
life decision
a lot you know like we said again like
we said on these this video series never
times you're going to look stupid and
you're going to take risk and there's a
chance
you're going to be like that was a huge
mistake
and
you want to like barter with the
universe you wanna you wanna be like
come on can i
can't i like
do you risk this like you wanna think
that you can be smarter than the system
to somehow give up nothing and have no
downside and only have upside
and the
yeah the more you want to try to barter
with the universe to be like okay first
i'll get a job at google and i'll save
money and then i'll do you know i'll
invest in crypto and then i'll do like
you want to like barter with the
universe to have no risk
and i guess like
i get where i feel i get where people
are coming from i just i'm not sure
that's a real thing and i think it's
being more real with yourself is like
yeah i'm taking risks like yeah quitting
my job at google is a risk and this i
may regret it
but i may not and but i'm doing this
with eyes wide open
and by actually putting my full heart
into anything i do whatever that is
including not quitting my job
that's how can you have regrets about
that being proud of the work you do i
mean this is what i tell a lot of folks
i do a lot of office hours of people
that are shutting down i did one today
you know it's like their final office
hours because they're showing another
startup but i i tend to tell people
similar stuff which is like look
if you're proud of the job you did
you know if you if you had a heart and
you gave it your all
and you feel like you learned stuff then
great job and you should view this as an
affirmative experience you didn't and so
like i'm proud of you i'm proud of the
job you did i know you had your heart
into this thing and like
we'll get the next one
you know i think that that message has
to be told because
it is rewarding
but founders have to be kind of reminded
that they didn't fail like it's not like
or let's just put it this way it's not
like failing a test that like uh a basic
math test that you just didn't study for
it's like it's not like that like
you tried to do something that so few
people in the world are successful at
failing is not really failing
like at all
it's like
it's like trying to be a pro athlete
like you're really good in college you
try to go pro and you like make a team
and then you get cut in the first year
like that's still pretty awesome yeah
you still were really one of the best
thousand people on earth who could play
basketball
yeah and so it's like
you know again it would be great if you
were number one in the world but like
people are gonna respect what you did
and you and if you if you're if you're
proud in your heart of the work you did
then you will view this as a positive
thing in your life you know
yeah
and i always tell the people who are
hedging i always say this the other side
you know in our world it's really
competitive and what happens if there's
a team that's exactly
as competent as you
and they're not hedging
they're always going to win
you know they're always going to beat
you so how much better do you have to be
than that team
if you're splitting your resources two
ways three ways four ways like
so it's not even a good strategy even if
you were trying to think strategically
unfortunately no um
so yeah
so there you go
those are some of the things that future
billionaires do to get [ __ ] done and
some of the things that they avoid as
well great chatbot
sounds good thanks man
[Music]
[Music]
you